[Music]
in blissing robot news submitted by the
man under wall who that was Chameli okay
a robot priest can be more light from
its hands and give automated blessings
to worshipers walked
oh that sounds very holy nice church
robot
yeah Church robot at least a church
priest will be holier than the human
breeze that's true they can't they don't
judge yep and they're not going to touch
little boys yep
a robot priests okay yeah that's on me
so the robot priest isn't going to go
like this and see a little boy and go
[Music]
the program over still a human yeah so
this robot whose official name is les
new - - ah is the second version of it
you - - I guess it's like less YouTube
bless you - bless you - anything you
like the letters are two dishes - so
yeah it's the same and so he he lives in
Germany Sherman Lee and so he was
created to mark the 500th anniversary of
the Protestant Reformation and reverse
Oh Martin Luther's yeah Martin Luther
you know Martin Luther nah Martin Luther
King but Martin Luther he's the guy that
went against the Catholic Church and he
said guess what everybody should read
the Bible and then he said like you know
what we're gonna do some crazy [ __ ] and
then they use a printing press and say
hey we're going to make the Bible
available for everybody and then the
catalog says [ __ ] that [ __ ] only we had
the power [ __ ] we're gonna [ __ ]
you up
and then Martin Luther said no [ __ ] you
because like I want a direct connection
with God that's what happened
mmm and much I like him yeah so this
year Korea is the 500 year since you did
that it's been a long time
mm-hmm so that's why that's why they
created this robot to commemorate that
how do they have it put the Holy Spirit
in this robot though are you a video
they took this to see the always fair
it they take the human out of them and
there's the holy spirit this is the we
are dinner
how cute that guy it's how I got you I
know yes
so by the way they said that they did
create this robot intentionally to not
look anywhere near a human then why did
they have eyebrows I know and he has
expressions what you see he should come
inside a magician doesn't mention all of
your different flags there's a different
language yeah you can speak in seven
languages vision seems Aussies are you
gonna do a blessing right now
what's the Edition 41 position I feel
like an acolyte the clarity is an under
the oath to shrink one oh so scary you
know you put this
[Music]
be hidden freakin gorgeous and fleeting
Ozzy Osbourne's he doing a prayer I'm
confused now you feel like a blessing
haha so that's that and then this is a
printed blessing Oh print for you you
gotta hide like a two dollar charge or
something put a coin in there first
they haven't reported if they're
charging Oh so what makes this creature
so holy spirit oh who did like like one
of the wizards of God come over and like
magic wand him I mean like or do people
like the idea of a robot that's giving
out blessings we're gonna hate it so
there is half and half they're saying
that half of them think that it's
brilliant but the other half just cannot
imagine getting a blessing from a robot
why the robot is more holier than a
human being I live about kind of looks
shitty though he looks like a junkyard
robot like it doesn't look well-designed
I've seen slot machines I look better
than that [ __ ] I think they
should have just put on a proper attire
that I'm used to some wood puppet I'm
letting this Cape and I had hair all the
way around his head and just bald on top
I don't know I think that's the proper
time he's Podesta right so he needs a
cloak a brown one like Martin Luther
King oh yeah like that I think I would
take more sushi this looks like a little
kid thing yeah I mean I kind of agree
with you Jo where it's like I feel like
the function of the robot is very it
looks like it's pretty impressive but
like because it looks so cartoonish at
the same time I don't know if I could
take it seriously yeah I can't take a
blessing seriously from this robot
blesses me [ __ ]
I'm not very religious but what is the
point of a blessing from a robot all
right just in general we need David but
didn't you go to the Catholic Church I
know about I try to forget everything
but they did they do that for you
because none of us grew up Catholic
except you Ray it was
another really grow up Catholic it was
like I was baptized and that's pretty
much it because they don't I don't think
they do blessings in a non Catholic or
Orthodox Christian or whatever or what's
the point of a blessing season we didn't
I didn't have a blessing
wow we only had prayers really huh it
yeah it might be like she got the holy
water spray all over the place yeah yeah
we never hit we never did the blessing
stuff
I just know breath you when you sneeze
that you remember a confession from
enhancing and same confirmation things
but I didn't learn anything they put the
thing in your mouth yeah that's a weird
little potato chip yeah put it in your
mouth and you have an option you can do
this thing and they put it here and you
can put it in your own mouth it put it
in my own mouth when I did communion is
it yummy yeah yeah why are you doing
this tarah flavorless okay so I think
Catholics you have the priestess or the
mr. priest that puts it in your mouth
right but can also get in your head oh
but then like although you can receive
it yeah but non Catholic just like I
guess all the other Christians or
whatever during the ceremony I don't
know if they pass it around like you
know that money thing that they pass
around and then you pick one out and
then they do a ceremony and they they
talk about the scripture about me he's
my crash oh yeah yeah and then when they
pass around the Welch's grape orange
juice I mean double grape juice Lars is
wine they gave children why me well you
can't treat another kid
yeah I thought it was Welch's grape
juice ally so I know that was my
favorite [ __ ] Welch's grape juice and
[ __ ] a special way to break baked a
biscuit
although the biscuit was like whatever
and they did a prayer for that [ __ ] and
I was like I can't wait for this man I
don't have a fishing yeah because I grew
up with my best friend being Christian
and we saw we'd go to her church and
they never did it depends on the time of
the year I went every like throughout
the year you every weekend not every
single weekend there's a time when this
happens
like it's not done every time for
Catholic Church I think it's done every
time every time I big the Catholic
Church the ISM well you get up smack
every time yeah it doesn't taste like
anything it's like cardboard so I love
it what is that supposed to symbolize
along with like the wine is taking what
you're you're taking the body of Jews
and his holy eating as dancers you're
drinking his blood and you're [ __ ]
eating its flesh yeah and like that the
wine represents the blood that's all I
know
that is literally all I know how are
people taking this role because I feel
like it's like you know the religion is
a very spiritual experience regardless
of what the religion is so it's just
very like supernatural and you feel this
connection with a greater being and then
you got this like man man man right
coming out of nowhere
look I feel like it's like it's religion
then you got real life in science and
then this is even more on this side yeah
well like I said like there's half of
them that I can't have some that don't
but it seems like the the reason why we
created this robot was more to like
bringing tore it to and then they're
saying like they've had and it like
they've had way more people visit the
church than they've ever had so far so
like they're getting more people to step
foot in the church to see also is chemic
they said he stunned there's me better
marketing well no it just has been
having so much bad marketing I think
they're just trying to get what if they
do like a Groupon deal five people that
go to the church they get 20 of those
little chippings
that's a pretty good one or they could
do a Groupon deal for like I'll pray for
your thin yeah so you like [ __ ] send
a lot this month man
I think I'm jacked off every week all
right so I'm gonna pay for that Groupon
deal and then you can erase all your two
more sins forgiven yep that's what I
think so I smoked it going i dag dal
friday night told my mom oh shut up
[Laughter]
but you get all your Apes yeah whenever
I would go to confession because I went
to a Catholic school for one semester
when I was in the sixth grade and like
they would make us go and I'm like what
am I supposed to do here like tell em
all your secrets and I'm like dad tell
them everything you did wrong and I'm
like what you said yelled at my brother
exact you know like I don't know I'm
like I don't know what sins I mean I
could never be a priest
I'm too far we start laughing I'm too
into drama like issues she's like yeah
so like you know me and my dad got in a
fight and I told him this I'm like
really and it will happen like really
and then what happened and I would just
want to know all the details just for
entertainment you open up that thing
that's what hold up so you tella be baby
would your daddy been fighting for three
years and you just you talk [ __ ] - all
the time I could never do that I get my
house beat this happens I think you fit
your brain so they're like when you say
this stuff they're like three Hail Marys
like what exactly is a Hail Mary because
I don't know what this is it's a prayer
oh did you say your prayer then your
students go away is that pretty much I
guess that's the way they yeah I hated
it I'd only did it once my life so you
got a like eight candles pay us 50 bucks
and say 20 Hail Marys and get here
trends it's okay if you lost your
virginity before marriage yeah pretty
much the way worries away and I was
never into the whole religion thing
because I'm like system so like old
institutionalize like big religions are
like that it's kind of like even
Buddhism and stuff if you go you know
when we went to Japan and they had all
those like papers on the wall and all
that it's just people buying wishes so
it's like please let me do good on my
test can you pay money and [ __ ] tie
that on the wall and you're like yes I'm
gonna do good on my test
it is like [ __ ] just study [ __ ] did ya
moms always pay for that [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
she always has her name written
somewhere on some temples in some place
in the world at least it makes her feel
good right makes her feel good yeah yeah
so I guess it's kind of working thing I
hate
[ __ ] you know why stupid because it
makes people run away from their
problems none of me and they don't
[ __ ] face their own [ __ ] and
challenge themselves they go oh well you
know what um I wish I could get a job so
I'm going to go to church and like do
some prayers and pay money and do all
that stuff and then maybe God will give
me a job or like same thing in the
Buddhist religion you know like oh you
know I'm really hoping that I get good
grades this year so I'm just going to
pay it's like this just study harder or
do more interviews or like you know I
mean like sure because I have a friend
that like she turned into like super
like very religious and like she's just
always really sad and depressed as your
life's not going where she wants it to
go and you doing prayers from all the
same [ __ ] yeah players and then they
they think that God or some higher
beings going to handle it now I got it
yeah worried about that problem because
she's just sitting at home like moping
around all day wait and she tell her I'm
like well are you trying to find a job
or your time about your business exactly
and that's like her answer for
everything I'm like we gotta you know be
active in your own life as well it just
can't be all up to God they got
selective reading because there's they
probably didn't get to this part in the
Bible but it's this like um God only
helps those that help themselves
that's right hello my mother Joe Malians
please like the video and for more
beautiful videos look up there
[Music]
you
[Music]